talk about the old man the guy's name is
jack buck right he
was a uh local saint louis guy
who uh you know called the games and
then went national too
right he got a little taste of uh kind
of doing the big game on network
television in the early night and your
dad was a good guy
to you because you took an interest in
sports announcing and he would critique
your tapes he would uh
do a point and and what i'm grateful for
is he wasn't riding me like i would be
13 14
15 and i would do the game into a tape
recorder in an empty booth and then he
and i would listen to the tape on the
way home
but it wasn't you know well here's how i
would have done it here's here's what
you should have said here it was just
kind of let me
find my own way so then by the time i
was 19 i left college i was doing
aaa baseball and i got hired to do the
cardinals when i was 21.
and he and i were partners then he and i
were broadcast partners but you even
said the devastating part of
sitting next to your father or working
in that environment
suddenly the the st louis newspaper
writes why are we being force-fed
joe buck and that devastated you right i
mean i it was before i even got on the
air
it was right i mean that's how human
nature is and there's no way
i'm sitting there if i'm not jack buck's
kid
right why did you carry that article
around with you in your wallet it was
motivation
was it it motivates me to to work hard i
it was a good you know i cried like a
baby when something like that's written
about you
you feel like the whole world is
thinking hates you
hates you and and and i was like my god
i haven't even begun
meanwhile the guy who wrote it probably
like just did it flippantly you know
what i mean
yeah and like probably never gave it
another it's an easy article to write
yeah and you know he and i become
friends and when my dad was dying in the
hospital
that guy who wrote that article about me
when i started
he was still in that position and he was
kind of pumping me for information about
my dad because the whole community
is waiting for my dad to get out of the
hospital now i knew
he wasn't going to get out of the
hospital he had lung cancer and he had
parkinson's diabetes all these other
things and it wouldn't allow him to heal
so he's he's in the hospital he gets an
infection
and he's just withering away and i'm
visiting i'm there every day
and he's mouthing because he had a trach
deal too
will you do me a favor will you
let me die and
it took me back a little bit and i i
said dad
i know it's frustrating but i'm on the
outside
and i'm talking to the doctors we're
going to beat this we're good he goes
will you let me die i said
let's give this two weeks if it doesn't
get better and he's just kind of
brushed me off like get out of here you
know you're you're pissing me off you're
not listening to me so
two weeks go by he goes through a series
of strokes the head of the hospital
comes to me and he says
you know i'm gonna tell this to you as
your friend
your dad's not getting out of here we
will do everything we can to keep him
alive
but he's not leaving this hospital right
i said okay he said so you need to find
a day when this is going to end
so we picked the day the day starts they
pull all the tubes out of them he's been
on a respirator
they took his pacemaker out uh you know
for once he was clean you know instead
of beeping and all these noises
everything he's in his bed
and everybody's wait now the night
before i went in there and i said
everything i wanted to say to him
i was with my first wife consciousness
with my sister he was conscious
yeah and i said you know i i want you to
know that it's okay
to go i've got mom i've got julie i'll
take care of
of everything right you've done
everything you can do
now be ready to go peacefully
well the next day comes they pull all
this stuff out of him
and everybody shows up and i said you
know what
this isn't a movie i don't need to watch
him die right i said what i wanted to
say
so i'm getting updates from my sister
who's there 10 o'clock
he's alive 11 o'clock he's alive 12
o'clock he's alive one
two three four five and i have to go
down and do a cardinal baseball game on
tv
and so i went to work because i knew
that's what he would want me to do
and they pulled the tv down by his head
and they let him listen
to the broadcast while i was on there
wow and he listens to the he's
he's alive without any help he's been in
there for seven months
on a respirator no help whatsoever i get
in my car i drive by i drive home and on
the way home is the hospital
right off the highway and i pull off
and i i'm gonna go again so i walk up
i go to his room it was peaceful
i bent down into his ear i said goodbye
again
told him everything was covered i walked
out and by the time i got to my car he
was dead
and there's just there there was a bond
we had and there was something there
that i think he wanted me to say goodbye
and and for him to to stay alive that
entire day
was everything he was about he was the
toughest guy i knew
he was your best friend he was he was my
best friend and for him to let me trail
around
with him on all these road trips uh
and and to see the life and to see the
joy he got out of that life
was the greatest gift he could ever give
me it set me up for the rest of my life
whether
i got to start because of nepotism i got
the love because of him